- Okay girls, I'm gonna
say whatever I think.
(inspirational music)
- To all the girls out
there who actually like
wanted to be perfect,
perfect doesn't exist.
- You don't have to become
Britney Spears or Beyonce
in order to be happy.
- Confidence is not something
that happens overnight.
Don't rush yourself.
- Every room you enter, you belong in.
You're not supposed to not be somewhere.
You're not the person who doesn't belong.
You're not the person
who should be sitting
in the back of the room.
If you're in that room, you're
supposed to be in that room.
You're probably the smartest
person in that room,
and act like it.
- As long as you're doing one thing,
one thing a day to make
yourself feel empowered
or feel loved, or just look
at yourself in the mirror,
and go, "Dang girl, you look good today."
Loving yourself is a process,
and everybody is on their own clock.
- Be free.
Be wild.
Stay creative.
- Write a song.
You need to talk about yourself.
You need to like let it out.
- You are responsible
for your own happiness,
and you need to go and find it.
- Even your most depressing days
are a part of your evolution.
- Life is just about
believing in yourself,
believing in your dreams,
and you are the dream.
So as long as you're
believing in yourself, you are
completing everything that
is necessary for you here
in this time, in this
lifetime, in this moment.
- What you have to offer
is everything that we need.
Believe that.
- There is so much power in each other.
- It's important to know that
you have a community of girls
and women supporting you.
I am one of those people.
- We are here for you! (chuckles)
- Find happiness in little things,
and they will get bigger
and bigger and bigger.
- At the end of the day, if you
are striving for perfection,
you're never going to get what you want.
What you need to strive for
is being your true, authentic self.
And that is when you're
going to really find peace,
you're gonna find success,
and you're gonna find love
in the best way possible.
- I think the most important
thing is to just be you
'cause nobody else is.
- My parents were
amazing, and they told me,
as long as I could
dream it, I could be it.
And I truly believe that.
And so that means to this
day, I'm pretty sure I could
still win an Olympic gold
medal in figuring skating,
even though I'm way too old,
(logo whooshes)
So, but if I can dream
it, I can be it, right?